depuis combien de temps sait nager
fin des années 60 les écoliers français
investissent les piscines publiques la
natation scolaire commence seulement à
se généraliser
pourtant elle est obligatoire depuis
1879 à angers où seul un bassin est
disponible pour 90 classes d'écart sont
mis à disposition des élèves
ça permet chaque année à 3000 enfants de
passer dans la piscine et de bénéficier
d'une très large initiation à la
natation la natation fait partie
intégrante du programme scolaire même
titre que les matous le français mais
son enseignement reste limitée car la
france manque d'équipement monsieur que
pensez-vous de l'apprentissage de la
natation scolaire
je serai très bien mais il manque
beaucoup plus une
l'appel est entendu 1971 le gouvernement
réagit y lancent l'opération 1000
piscine
le but favoriser l'accès de la natation
un maximum d'élèves de ces piscines sont
d'un prix relativement peu élevé 1
million 200 mille francs et seront
surtout livré clé en main c'est à dire
sans al les aléas de la hausse des prix
l'opération bénéficie à des centaines de
communes des infrastructures sortent de
terre comme ici à saint raphaël en 1974
avec la construction d'une piscine
tournesol la charpente métallique de ce
type de piscine vitré est fermé en hiver
ou lycées sur elle mène à 180 degrés en
été pour s'ouvrir de péter oublier le
solde
grâce à ces piscines préfabriqués les
cours de natation se normalise à l'école
exemple à roubaix en 1977
es tu prêt ici
l'aluminier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la natation scolaire est
obligatoire pour tous du primaire au
lycée
cette année en revanche pas de cours
pour les élèves les piscines sont
toujours fermés en raison de la crise du
coville 19 conséquence environ 800 mille
élèves n'ont pas pratiqué la natation
[Musique]